hello everyone
and welcome to rational science directly
from
frankfurt germany live live live
live live and today we're going to do a
review of the month
of the of march and
i'm going to be doing first a little bit
of extinction
theory okay then i'm going to do a
little review
of what we did this month which was
primarily geometry
geometric figures and i'm going to do
that with questions that people ask
because that'll drive the whole
conversation and at the end uh
i'm going to open the floor for any
questions that you may have so
get them ready get them started we'll
try to answer as many as we can
what is the circle let me start by
saying tomorrow's april fool's day
and i celebrate 45 years of marriage
45 years with the same woman and no
regrets
and i can only wish for everybody out
there to have
the same kind of marriage that i had had
a great marriage
we had great adventures with my wife and
we only made one big mistake in our
lives and that's this guy
here and i told her abort
abort and she said but i wouldn't know
what he looks like oh brother
and that's how he why he is disappointed
okay so let's get started there was a
fella who asked the question in
regards to extinction i just i'm just
going to cover his question
because i think it's important to go
through the little steps
there okay so let's go with this
question and he says the following
i can get it up here uh
what mechanism did you think of for the
sudden disappearance
of some types of plants that were direct
and unique nourishment for some animals
remember the theory is that
we had collapse of the
ecological collapse essentially the
overturning of the
ecological pyramid and what this appears
is primary production
and that's what he's referring to here
okay okay
so uh let me start by clarifying this
okay we want to distinguish background
extinction from
mass extinction two different mechanisms
according to this site okay
to this channel okay mass extinction
many species background extinction
one species disappears okay
um what's the general mechanism in the
case of a mass extinction and again
we're talking about
animals here okay overturning of the
ecological pyramid
and in the background extinction is the
overturning of the population
pyramid it's the demographic pyramid
that overturns
what causes the first one the
overturning of the population pyramid of
plants
okay the plants suffer their
long-term uh decline finally
and all animals that forge the
relationship with these plants for
millions of years
all these families they go down with the
plants
the ones that eat these plants die and
then the carnivores that ate the
right plant eaters and and the other
issue there is that they can't switch at
the last moment you know
a rabbit doesn't go from lettuce to
to bark or to christmas tree leaves
you know from morning to night he can't
switch
overnight and in the case of the
background extension what causes it are
extensive inbreeding
the founders effect and population
bottlenecks that's in general terms and
there's the example
of john calhoun's mouse utopian universe
he ran many experiments they all ended
in extinction
because what happens again is you have a
group of animals that
are born or expand
demographically from very few
grandfathers so that's essentially it
and let me put this up here now and
that's a little disclaimer for
when we talk about the aging of a
species okay
whether a species is old according to
mother nature has
nothing to do with how many times the
earth went around the sun
okay uh it has to do with something else
and here are the telltale
telltale signs that a species is likely
old
and you'll note that all of these refer
to man
man is an old species uh what are these
uh
uh science clues uh numerous individuals
high density we're what eight billion
people
uh large uh for a given species we're a
large
mammal and among the primates
we we are also big and that's known as
today is copes law
that means that animals
you know start out relatively small and
over time they grow bigger and bigger
and bigger
okay and that's how the t-rexes became
big and that's how we became made
they're sedentary they no longer
colonize the land
we can no longer colonize the land we
have already colonized the land
okay t-rex is called holidays the land
yeah when you reach a certain region and
then you don't expand anymore
essentially you become
sedentary you don't migrate anymore for
whatever reason you know that's the end
of you
the redwoods in california they are
sedentary as well they don't they used
to migrate i mean they used to cover the
planet in different parts
and they no longer migrate endemic
diseases
they become resistant to it and that's
part of the reason
you know they're sedentary they get used
as the diseases
locally and they are able to withstand
them after a while
after trial and error okay low
reproduction
and also low genetic diversity
those are in general terms the
characteristics of
a a species that is old and we meet all
those conditions humans
okay not that we're going to die in a
background extinction
but if you look at the neanderthals they
also
met all those conditions okay
okay um so i'm going to talk
to answer this gentleman's uh question
i'm going to talk about the permian
because i think that's a pretty good
example of what how the animals
disappeared because of food
okay what changed was their environment
and by their environment i mean their
food not
not anything else not the weather the
climate anything like that
and here you have a little map of
pangaea
this is what the permian looked like
in those days the end of the permian 252
million years ago
and in the south you'll see that green
area
that was covered by glossopteris a type
of seed fern
that covered all those regions and
that's how they think that all these
pieces of continents or some hard
continents in the
today were pieced together they were
they were part of the same puzzle
because this plant covered that whole
region and so did some of the animals
that lived in those days they can find
them in all these same places
and panty is divided into parts of
gondwana which is the
southern part of you know south of the
equator and
north you have lorasia in long asia you
get to
russia and you get to perm the region of
perm that's where the word permian comes
from
and there you will find also seed firms
you have tatarina
priscillancia and promotica and
all these are seed ferns they
disappeared together with the
glossopterists
in the southern hemisphere and yeah it's
very concerning when these
plants disappeared the animals
disappeared
so it's kind of cool to say i know what
you think and
did seed prints die out completely now
in the triassic you have
the dichroidiums which is a different
type of
seed fern that continued but it was a
seed fern that
these animals wouldn't have eaten uh
remember the triassic was the age of the
archosaurus
crocodile-like animals they governed the
triassic
for the most part and they dicrodiums
uh the herbivores of that age ate
dicrodiums
you say well a seed firm is a seed
german isn't the same thing animals can
eat one or the other well that's like me
asking you if you can eat
weeds i mean weeds are angiosperms and
they're flowering plants
but we don't eat weeds we eat lettuce
maybe tomato you know maybe some orange
or whatever
but we don't eat we don't eat these uh
weeds and they're all angiosperms
and that's how you have to look at this
dicrotions are not the same thing as
these uh glissopteros okay there were
different types of seed plants
uh seed ferns plants and so they
couldn't switch overnight to the
dichroiums
okay that's in general terms
these are the animals you'll find in the
south uh
area in south africa known as the karoo
and you look at those and say okay it
looks like a lion and the other one
looks like a hippopotamus maybe you know
moss chops and uh bradysaurus and uh
there's a little difference
between these animals what we have today
and let me give you uh an example here
so that you can put it in the right
context
imagine a lion that lays eggs
okay does that make sense you say oh
what do you mean the line that lays eggs
well these animals as you as you see
them they laid eggs
so they're known as mammal-like reptiles
they had more reptilian
characteristics than they had mammalian
okay
and so uh you know that's that's the
type of animal that
disappeared in the kuru okay
up north in siberia uh you had uh
there's the region you have the perm
region you have the
so-called key uh assemblage zone that's
where they find a lot of these animals
and plants
that's uh heavily studied today that
whole that whole region
and these are the animals that you'll
find in there you'll find innocence
okay which is a type of i guess
tiger lion whatever you want to think of
that is and you had a
scutosaurus which was a pariah sar and
the types of plants as
again you see them there on the right
okay they were seed ferns
that's what they looked like more or
less that's how we've reconstructed them
today
and you'll read on the bottom left there
that there were four orders
of these seed plants and they're
referred to terror those sperms
and i'm not even gonna bother
pronouncing these things i don't know
why the paleontologists
invent all these weird names for them
but uh essentially these seed ferns
were around they were maybe 90 percent
of the
flora out there at the time in some
places there were only
some of these plants and when they
disappeared what do you think the
animal's going to eat he's going to
switch overnight and say well i think
i'm going to eat conifers now which was
the next
uh group of plants to come you know into
the landscape
i think i'll switch overnight and say uh
i'm gonna start eating cycads now
no never happened never will okay they
can't switch overnight not after forging
a relationship of millions of years i
bet they tried on their last days
i don't think so you know it's like get
hungry enough
we'll try it a lot of people will say
that i don't feel digested but i'll try
it
yeah that's another one uh one thing is
that you want to eat to fill your
stomach you know some people
that were caught in a situation where
they were starving they started eating
bark
in desperation and and yeah and it
doesn't help them because it's not food
for the body it's not nutrients so you
can't
you can eat it i mean you can swallow it
maybe it calms your stomach but it
doesn't do anything for your body
because
it just goes through you don't have the
uh you don't have the bacteria that can
you know digest all that stuff for you
okay
uh important to note uh there this was
the
only insect extinction that happened
also in the permian
and we read you see there it says the
end permea is the largest known mass
extinction of insects
according to some sources it is the only
insect mass
extinction and they say insects were
piercing and sucking mouth parts began
to decline during the mid
permian and these extinctions have been
linked to what
to a change in flora okay
and from the uh you know with the end of
the
paleozoic uh you enter this region
this this age that lasts even until
today where the insects essentially
uh can tell who their grandfathers were
before that you know the
the insects that belonged before that
became
extinct and completely and here let me
give you some examples
uh this fellow here he's known as
arthropleura and uh
he lived in the carboniferous is that
being centipede yeah two and a half
uh meters you can see the size of that
and there's the uh there's the fossil
and
you look at that monster and you say
jesus i don't want to see him in a dark
alley you know
and it turns out he was a hair before
okay this animal was a herbivore
bullet yeah they they figured out by
their stomach contents that kind of
stuff
or the plants that were around them for
different reasons or the mouth parts and
so on they
decided he was a herbivore
but in the uh permian you get this
monster
okay and this is a little uh dragonfly
yeah two two feet long um
wingspan and um and this guy was a
carnivore
okay and maybe he grew that big because
he didn't have too many enemies
especially when he got to that size he
pro you know you probably wanted to
avoid him like to clamp them down you
don't need a fly sweater you need a
baseball bat
yeah so these were big monsters that you
had in those days all those animals
animals right insects right they
disappeared and then a new wave
of insects that last even until today
essentially
you know covered the land and uh so all
i can show you
uh to answer the question here is the
plant evolution this gives you a
a snapshot of what i'm talking about
you know you have different ages and
every age
has its plant in every age because it
has a
certain type of plant it also has a
certain type of animal that depends
on that plant herbivores first and
carnivores that
you know live off the fat of the land of
the herbivores
and you know you have the uh early part
i'm just going as far back as the
devonian and carnivorous
and you'll see the non-vascular and
early vasculars you'll have the horse
tails
you know you have certain type of plants
that essentially disappeared today
there are other varieties of horse tails
today but nothing to do with
the ones that existed in the
carboniferous from there we went to the
age of ferns you can call it
specifically the seed ferns but you know
ferns after all
and those were the permian and triassic
then when you have the
jurassic which is known as the age of
cycads
jurassic was all cycads all these other
plants vanished completely
and they were in the background like the
uh you have ferns in the background
but they're not the primary part of the
landscape okay of the flora
and then uh you know when uh the angus
burns i showed the graph the other day
the angiosperms displaced
the conifers that's when we came into
being and that's when the dinosaurs
disappeared
so i'm saying that when the plants die
that these
uh species these families of species uh
forced a long-term relationship with
when the plants go
so do the animals go and that's why we
don't see dinosaurs around today
okay and a way of speaking it's as if
all the food we ate
disappeared but food that other animals
eat
was still around and that's what
differentiates
why some animals survive that's that's
the
that's the uh discriminating factor
one food chain goes away because it
depends on a certain type of flora
you know the herbivores on that and uh
carnivores on that on those guys
and all the others are even uh are
completely unaffected
with what happens you know to the the
big guys usually it's the big guys that
go away and the small guys who are
radiating with the new vegetation they
don't know what's going on they say hey
you know we don't have the big guys
stomping on us anymore
let's explain that's an important part
that's never taught in schools and stuff
they always talk about the circle of
life and like the food chain but they
don't talk about food chains
with plural there's plural food chains
parallel to each other
one can go down without the other one
falling but
it usually is spoken as in the food
chain as if everyone is connected
yeah and that's not that's not true
because not everyone is connected there
could be maybe a little a tiny
connection maybe at the
insect level that maybe is so far
removed from us that that not what
supports us
i'll give you an example in the
cretaceous what died
were the diatoms and the other
foraminifera
and plankton in general
those were eaten by the ammonites
and the mosasaurs which were these big
monsters reptiles
not not fish reptiles that lived in the
sea
they ate or they subsisted primarily on
on ammonites this was a food chain and
guess what you know all three of them
disappear
now now that's kind of weird isn't it
that yeah
just the three that disappear the
asteroid hit exactly those three
just hit him right on the nose yeah yeah
it's very strange that that would happen
now you would think that it's got
something to do with food
and that's mother nature's um henchman
food that's what she uses to kill
species massively in a mass extinction
okay
and so that's the answer to this
gentleman's question
okay let me get to the uh um
review of this month which was primarily
geometry
we covered the uh
i don't want to hear about triangles and
squares no no these are circles squares
we had the semicircle we had the the
triangle
uh and the bottom line or the main
message was
no one has any idea what those
geometries are
why well now we're going to get into the
questions that people ask and you'll see
why and the kind of answers i'm going to
give them but then and they're not just
uh devil's advocate questions
no no no no no even if they're a devil's
question i mean a devil's advocate
question
yeah they're a fair game i don't have a
problem with that yeah the guy wants to
you know take it to the limit some of
those questions like why do you need the
answer for that yeah okay let's
so let's go to the limit no problem okay
this fellow says
what is the difference between geometry
and physics
okay geometry has irrational foundations
okay why specifically the point the line
and the plane
what's a point a location what's a line
an itinerary what's a plane a hollow
boundary okay so are any of these
geometric figures
figures is this what we understand by a
geometric figure an itinerary
a location is that a geometric figure
and so we have a problem because they
point to a geometric figure
but the description or the definition
has nothing to do with what they're
pointing to
that's that's the main point that i'm
trying to get through
so that means that the foundations are
irrational you're saying specifically a
point isn't a dot
it's a location which is a concept
you're saying a line isn't
a static uh continuous
uh line yeah it's an itinerary where you
place a whole bunch of dots yeah and a
plane is a hollow boundary
yeah it's a holly it's just a perimeter
but what is the perimeter it's just a
some itinerary going around you know in
the case of a circle it's just a
orbit and so on you know in other words
it's a bunch of locations locations of
whatever point that's going around
what's the point is a location we have a
location going from location to location
because there's nothing in the location
so it's a bunch of verbs and counting
but no
yeah no shapes so that's that's my
argument okay that's my this found
the foundations of geometry are rotten
why
because they try to merge physics with
mathematics
and those two uh cannot be merged
mathematics is a language physics is a
science
one has nothing to do with the other and
they cannot be merged under any
circumstance
okay so geometry is the is the vein
attempt to merge mathematics
which is what quantitative descriptions
with physics which is a qualitative
explanation or a bunch of qualitative
explanations
geometry is not a part of science
because geometry doesn't explain
any phenomena okay
science is explaining and geometry
doesn't explain
jam is just a description and what does
it do it's just
an exercise in ratios and relations you
know you look at angles you look at
lines how long a line is and that sort
of thing okay
so there is no no explanation coming out
of geometry
except when mr einstein tried to say
that you know gravity is a geometric
theory and we'll get to that i guess
physics on the other hand is a branch of
science rational explanations
what of mechanisms you have to explain
something and hopefully in physics what
we explain
are mechanisms the other guys end up
with a movie in his head
and math doesn't give you any movies
yeah
it's just uh you know you look at an
angle you look at the
you calculate you know if you have a
ratio between two lines or whatever
things of that nature and all those are
descriptions
in the best of cases you have no explain
it it doesn't explain anything it
doesn't explain gravity
uh except for mysteries it doesn't
explain light it doesn't explain
you know or how light works for example
the slit experiment or
i don't know uh polarization anything
like that
it doesn't explain gravity it doesn't
explain um magnetism
you know what are you going to explain
with with geometry jim is just a
a you could say a study in uh
in uh calculations related to angles to
to sizes of things ratios relations that
sort of thing
just a description that's all math
geometry is okay
um so let's get to the specific uh
issue this fella says
get this thing in there okay in geometry
point is a
location he's saying that okay and he
got this
out of somewhere and i said the same
thing the other day but yeah that's what
everybody understands it's a location
that has
what zero height zero width zero length
zero dimensions uh so far he described
nothing that's i guess the definition of
nothing zero nothing
that's zero zero everything so concepts
such as locations don't have dimensions
i mean does intelligence have dimensions
length within height
does energy have dimension does mass
have dimensions does a field have
dimensions
what dimensions length with height what
what dimensions do these concepts have
x y and z
and then that which has no dimensions is
not a figure
so if if uh a point does not have any it
doesn't have
zero uh has zero width zero length zeros
dimensions
well so far you describe nothing and
nothing is not a figure
so there you have the point of geometry
right underneath the
the uh arrow there that's what it looks
like like
nothing okay so yeah
you can't say that if if geometry must
start with a figure
you cannot say the point belongs to
geometry because the point is a location
location cannot be described in terms of
dimensions
and that which has no dimensions is
nothing
so so far we have nothing in front of us
okay which is what a black hole is
because the black hole is zero
dimensional
uh from every point of view remember
chandrasekhar proved it
mathematically and got a nobel prize for
it so you can't go back and say well no
that's not what he said
yeah chandrasekhar got a nobel prize for
putting an equation saying that
uh the the star collapses to zero size
and arthur eddington got so ups who was
his boss right who was his
you know guru uh objected to that did
not allow him to
uh print that stuff he published it
somewhere in both
einstein and eddington uh criticized
that and they said no a star cannot
collapse to zero size
these are their own words okay so uh
yeah don't tell me that black hole is
zero
uh size is not zero sign it is okay
it collapsed there's nothing stopping it
from continuing to zero
size because all they're gonna talk
about is mass not about the
structure so if it collapses to a point
all you have is a location
the center geometry yeah but that's part
of geometry in other words they're
saying that
uh because geometry enters the picture
especially in string theory where you
have you know this
uh collapse of a star it collapses to a
point
point geometry right geometry what's the
point location all we have is a location
full of
mass a concept full of another concept
so yeah that's how this stuff seeps into
the language uh
from geometry okay okay here's the line
okay a big important line very important
in uh
in so-called geometry what was the line
a bunch an
itinerary okay a line is defined as what
a line of points what was the point
location
wait a line is defined as a line well
line of points he means you know like
a bunch of points that's what he wants
to say like you know a sequence of
points that's
that's what he meant by line of point
but yeah what he's saying is it's a
bunch of location because we just
settled that
a point is a location so we have a
series of
locations what is that that's an
itinerary that's not a line
okay but they put a line a geometric
line usually a continuous line to
represent that
when there is no such thing as a
line made of a single piece a continuous
line of representing i think yeah
they represent a lot which is which is
and that's code for cheating and that's
that's the word they use they say no
that's a representation of a line that's
a representation of a point what do you
mean a representation
either is already yeah
yeah uh and then he says that extends
infinitely oh man extends an infinitely
we have two problems there okay
in two directions it has one dimension
length now there's no geometry that has
one
dimension okay so if a line is a bunch
of locations
points right uh then the line doesn't
extend
okay only objects may be said to extend
okay uh you're talking about something
else not extension
extension is when you extend your bubble
gum that's extending okay
but here we're talking about something
else a series of locations
is not a geometric figure okay and
that's what a line is according to
that definition there which is what
people have out there officially
um a series of locations known as and
what
itinerary an itinerary does not have
dimensions
length or height dimensions are the sole
province of
objects and figures only objects and
figures or
things can have dimensions you cannot
say a concept like intelligence or
information has dimensions it's
irrational
infinity or infinite is an adjective in
physics it is irrational to use it as an
adverb see you can't say it's infinitely
like you said there
now what he meant is something else a
series of points go on forever
incessantly you have to use an adverb
you can't use an adjective that you
force what's the difference between
infinite and incessant well the
infinite is uh referring to an object
you can say
assuming right that an object is
infinite which would
which is a contradiction because all
objects are finite but you can apply it
to the word object because it's an
adjective you can say this object is
infinite meaning
that it you know extends forever it's
devoid of verb
yeah in other words it occupies the
whole universe and beyond
it's like this object is infinite you
can use it in that sense
and that would be irrational because all
objects are finite but you cannot say i
run
infinitely you can say i run eternally
you can say i run incessantly
uh you know you can use adverbs for that
you can't use an
adjective and turn it into an uh adverb
in
in in these contexts that's what
he meant by extends infinitely so
you know the language is important
extend is a verb so i guess in
in if you took it literally it would be
like the bubble gum stretching forever
uh yeah but uh even in that case it
doesn't mean
yeah it extends yeah you can't say
infinitely okay
is infinitely even a word yeah it is a
word because it's used by mathematicians
who
talk about the number line like saying
you know uh
for example the real numbers you know
they extend forever
you can continue counting until you die
and beyond okay
even when you go to heaven okay uh
here's a line and what is it a bunch of
locations
so what we have is a turtle at different
locations that's all we have for a line
that's the definition
of line we have today just locations so
what they've done is they turned that
into a solid stick
okay which is not true it should not be
like that you mean a
series of locations that something goes
through i guess
yeah in other words the line of geometry
is just a bunch of locations and all
you're saying is that we have a turtle
there and it's got different locations
and and uh that turtle if you were to
put it in each frame of the universal
movie
that turtle would occupy one frame
for every split second yeah for every
location
between each split second and there's
another location
so all you have is more frames and every
family should get so complicated
what what fringe uh examples do they
need to go to the such lengths for
because uh they wanted to incorporate uh
physics with math in other that's what
geometry is an attempt to merge
the physical part which is what you can
see the figure
with the what they're going to do which
is oh we want to look right at ratios
and relations
and so they they said well this has to
do with math because we're going to be
doing angles and calculating sines and
cosines
and this has to do with physics which is
the object itself
and today that's why we don't have any
objects in so-called
physics in other words mathematical
physics they extracted all the all the
ratios and then they just left the
object yeah and they don't pay attention
to the objects because a mathematician
doesn't deal with objects
and that's how we ended up with this
which is the circle let me put it over
here
cover your face okay why because uh
what are you staring at well you're
staring at an orbit and what's orbiting
a location
yeah yeah the location is over location
is at different locations
because because the dot is not there the
dot is there to represent the location
what is the location it's just the the
location
occupied by a location because there's
nothing in that location
okay i'll take a shot every time
someone hears location yeah and so here
you have the uh
the square okay that's what a square
looks like
it's an itinerary we're just talking
about a location following location yeah
that's what it is that's all it is and
here we have the triangle we cover that
okay there's a triangle okay so all we
have is a bunch
of locations that's that's known as
geometry
those are figures that you stared at
that's what they're saying
so we have a rotten foundation for
geometry
and uh you're saying well who cares
because what we
were interested is in the ratios and the
relations all that stuff
yeah but see we have a problem because
then they extrapolate that to physics
and they start telling you that gravity
is a geometric
uh phenomena phenomenon
that's where the problem is that's where
the danger is okay because they say arch
geometry
i mean where do they get what is a
string and they say well it's a line see
it's not a string
it's a line okay let's let's get this
straight they use the word string you
say okay i know what a string is
string string theory uh here you have
that's a string right we all understand
what a string is okay
you see it there and they say it's a
string and we say okay i understand what
a string is in fact a lot of people
think that
these people are talking about strings
they're not talking about strings
they're talking about line because
they're doing all this mathematically
that you're not supposed to the string
is there to represent what's that
again represent yeah let's represent the
line what is the string it's a bunch of
locations it's an itinerary
and what they're doing is they're
vibrating the itineraries
and that's the particle the particle is
a vibration
of an itinerary and until you understand
it you don't understand strength theory
string theory has nothing to do with
objects with strings
string theory has is a geometric theory
okay so geometric theory that tries to
explain
gravity that's trying to unify general
relativity with quantum mechanics
what is quantum mechanics they use the
dot what is the dot it's a location
that that is the representation of
location they call it a particle but
you're talking about what
an equation and they're trying to unify
that they're trying to quantize
space-time meaning they're going to take
space time they're going to chop them
into little
dots quantum dots and with that they're
going to try to explain
how a black hole works because what
they're interested in
they that's where they think they can
merge the two the black hole
has the singularity that they get from
quantum mechanics and it has the
space-time curvature that they get from
space-time from
general relativity and so they're trying
to play around with that
mathematically and they say okay we came
up with strings
uh what do you mean by strings what's an
itinerary it's an italian what what do
you mean
it's full of locations and what they're
going to look
at is these relations between the
itineraries
and what happens inside a black hole
that's what they're that's what they're
doing
because they think that's where the uh
um
what is it the uh the golden no what was
it
the the i can't there's a term for the
golden
uh not the golden fleece i'm thinking
uh it's it's their goal their goal is
you know to
to merge these things and to again to
merge quantum mechanics with general
relativity and the way they do it
through
geometry because they say geometry works
you know gravity works in space time
works in general relativity and here we
have the point
which becomes a line that's geometry too
hey we got it all we got to do is
put them together okay that's the issue
that's where the danger is
uh with geometry they're introducing it
into their physical interpretations
and misleading you again because they're
not talking about objects
at all there are there are no objects in
mathematical physics not one
all the objects of mathematical physics
are what particles which are equations
black holes which are singularities
mathematical singularities
space time which is what what is time is
that a physical object no that's uh
a number and so on and so forth it's all
equations it's all uh uh
mathematical what they call objects no
it's not a mathematical object because
object is something else but they turned
it into a mathematical object so that
they could give you
a physical interpretations uh attation
and what do they use they use words such
as well that's a field and that's energy
and that's mass
and you think they're talking about
objects now they're talking about
uh mathematical concepts quantities
which is what they can put in their
equations was holy grail the word
that was where the holy grail yeah
that's the holy grail of
string theory to try to merge you know
quantum with uh
general relativity okay um
here we have another question and
says uh the word science does not mean
and will never mean
rational explanation science the
epistemy
or epistemological i guess is knowledge
the so-called man of science is simply
the man who knows
where did this come from uh yeah this is
a fellow who put this comment there
and the answer is no okay first of all
the word knowledge
has never been defined to this day we
don't have a definition for the word
knowledge so you can't use an undefined
word to define science
even though the word science comes from
sierra which is uh
the latin for knowledge that's when the
greeks and the romans
screwed up because science has nothing
at all to do with
knowledge and that's why we have to
define these terms to find out what they
meant and what
what it means today today we don't have
a definition for the word knowledge
everyone uses plato's justify true
belief
that's the definition of the word
knowledge today and knowledge
is equal to belief essentially knowledge
when you know
means that you have a belief because the
other guy on the other side of the
planet
his knowledge is a little different his
belief is a little different
so when you say that you know for a fact
uh that's your religion really along and
talk with you just like friends
and my brother kind of had a really good
example talking about
the flat earth theory how back back in
the day
medieval times they thought the world
world was flat and the earth was the
same
generous he said back then they knew
the world was flat and now we know it's
not so what does no mean
a lot of people know that god exists you
can't even talk about
it sounds trickier but i'm just saying
the flat earth one is a good example
yeah
that one is basically by a democracy how
many people
raise their hand up for this belief
that's the no
yeah and and you can do that today if
you have the flat earth thirst today and
they don't believe the earth is around
and you say hey
i know the earth is spherical i know the
earth is
round and they'll say that i know
differently
so who knows but when we kept saying
what's wrong with using the word belief
and they're like ah but that just sounds
so wishy way yeah yeah
he didn't like that word that's not a
good word for like science and like yeah
technology this is the day believe i
believe the
you know if you walk up as the architect
of the of a building
you say i believe this will this won't
fall that's less uh
yeah no this way i know i believe
you believe you better you better know
what do you mean you believe yeah it's
like a different
it's like a different weight to it
knowing yeah and so
uh here let's uh complete that here we
have it
okay so we have to define these terms
knowledge what is knowledge this is
according to my definition okay
now it's predicting the result of an
experiment without error
okay that's what knowledge means it's
always meant but that's in retrospect
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what we're
saying here
is that if you want to show your
knowledge to someone how do you show it
how do you show to the professors at the
university that you know
are you just going to say well i know
that napoleon went to waterloo
well how do you know i mean did you just
read a book and memorize
were you there how do you know that
napoleon went to waterloo so you cannot
talk about
knowledge in past tense in in
consummated events
you can talk about explanations you can
talk about descriptions you cannot talk
about
knowing that jesus christ was hanged
that
uh caesar went to england
you cannot talk about knowledge in that
sense you mean you're repurposing the
word so that you can only use it for
something you can predict
yeah and the only purpose of the word
knowledge
and the only way you can use it
consistently is saying look i can
predict what's going to happen
for example if i let go of a pen i let
go of the pen it falls to the floor i
know
it will fall to the floor and by that
you mean that you can predict
exactly that every time you let go of
the pen it falls to the floor
it turns out that you're even wrong
there because you say okay i'll bet you
a million dollars this is going to fall
to the floor
and it turns out a comet hits the earth
and neither one of you collects your bet
because the pen never made it to the
floor the the comet destroyed you didn't
know the comet was going to hit the
earth
for example so you cannot believe you
didn't leave the car you believe
that the or it turns out that you have a
horse
right and it turns out that you you say
i know that horse is going to win the
race
and that's because you maybe bribed all
the other jockeys or you put some
some device that hurts the other uh
horses or whatever
and you say okay i'll bet you a million
dollar your horse doesn't win your horse
number five won't win
and the guy says okay i'll bet you and
the horse is about to reach the finish
line i pull out my gun and shoot it it
never makes the
finish line and the others just walked
right through even the turtles pass up
so uh you didn't know that you're the
that the
horse was gonna win so the way you used
we have no no you can't use
you can't it would be incorrect in the
sentence uh i know the pen is red
right uh you can't predict the redness
of the pen well it would be a misuse of
the word
uh again uh in in that right it's a
misuse of the word because that's a
description we're talking about
predicting something that's going to
happen in the future okay so that's
what i'm saying knowledge means and that
word there has nothing to do with
science at all
science deals exclusively with the past
with consummated events there's the
definition
deals with theories explanations the
causes underlying a mechanism
physics or reasons that led to an event
philosophy
or the prosecutor's version of how or
why an event happened
happened past tense ed okay description
what we don't do in science is a listing
of properties or behaviors of an object
you do that too yeah but it's avoiding
it but that's not that's not the core of
science and people mistake the core of
science
and they say well we have to describe
and i'll get to that in a minute here in
fact uh so
i'm getting ahead of myself here let me
get that out
okay okay let's get to the next
issue here one person says talks about
wrong and right what's wrong what's
right yeah doesn't have to do with facts
well we'll get to that one of the
comments talking about
the difference between the earth being
flat being a belief or a fact
yeah okay look at that okay it said that
whoever this is the comment
person man said that whoever has a
degree in science wrong
wrongly defined as a scientist or
whoever is employed
in a scientific laboratory wrongly
defined is a scientist
or who simply deals with scientific
topics wrongly defined
is a scientist all wrong okay first
thing
wrong is an opinion right wrong that's
your opinion okay so whatever
whenever you use the words right wrong
correct incorrect
um true false all those are opinions
that doesn't enter science that's
totally religion
opinion belief religion and then the
second part of that is that this
argument merely corroborates that the
word science has
never been defined rationally because if
those are the definitions people have
out there
then we don't have a definition for
science if that's what the people think
that a scientist is
okay okay so uh let's get on to
another common question here give me a
second
pulled it from the bottom here
fella says
christ the defiance says science is well
defined
yeah no kidding uh and all the
dictionaries in the world say
more or less the same thing uh-huh okay
change the meaning of a word that humans
have been using for a
few millennia it is impossible
you have to use or invent something else
that's kind of what i keep saying too
and i'm saying no we have to fix what is
broken
science is defined irrationally we don't
have a rational definition of the word
scientist
science and we have no scientists on
planet earth because they're all
following this religion which
people call science oh i thought for a
moment it was a
it was cut off democracy voting you know
what this guy's referring to has nothing
to do with science they're not
scientific criteria
you can't say well we're going to vote
i'm going to vote on what the facts
yeah no no no on what the the word
science means we don't vote in science
in science you have to fight for your
definition you have to get into the ring
with your sword your shield right what
does that mean exactly
well you have to fight you have to
defend your definition and if someone
shows
right in a rational way you know in a
logical way that your definition has a
contradiction
i'm sorry you can say well i still
believe in it yeah you can believe in it
but you're not in science now you're in
religion
because there's a contradiction in what
you're saying right the guy shows you
patent that you have a patent
the obviously the definition uh
contradiction in your definition
and then again you can't use tradition
and authority which is what this guy is
saying he says
uh you you're trying to change the
meaning of the word that humans have
been using before
we've always used it yeah that's not a
that's not an excuse that's not an
argument well because we're not talking
about the word exactly we're more
talking about the notion
right what do we mean by science what is
the idea that we're trying to
to box into a word exactly exactly we
don't really care about the word
right more than just what's what's the
the notion that we're trying to get
and what i'm saying if it's broken you
got to fix it sorry
so we never had a good uh criteria for
this notion right
is what you're saying and so we need to
define what science is and
that's why you have to look at what the
science try to try to achieve
and i'm saying everybody that deals with
science
wants an explanation we want to know how
gravity works
we want to know how light what how light
does its magic
you know all these experiments that
people have seen out there observations
whatever
they say well tell me how mother nature
is doing that
trick that that uh magical trick right
that's why the mathematical physicists
also always
go into how things work yeah at the end
at the end of the dissertation at some
point they say and that's how magnet
works yeah but then when you tell them
hey but
the the uh explanation gave me is
irrational they say
well that's philosophy anyways or uh
you're not supposed to take it literally
representation again oh there we go
again that's why we need to define the
word science once and for all and today
science is really religion that's why we
need to define the word science
people have this mistaken idea that
science is about
uh convincing people persuading people
that that's what science is about saying
oh you know we proved it we proved it
yeah yeah
enough people believe it right now raise
their hands and vote that's one that's
thrown in my face
a lot you know whenever i bring it up
with my friends it's like
is that why so many black guys so many
people believe this you're gonna think
it's wrong it's one of those things like
like you're crazy one of those things
yeah i don't bring it up a lot but when
it comes up it's like
that's not really a good argument it's a
it's a delicate point yeah
it's like it's not really an argument a
million people believe this
does that make it true you know yeah i
mean i guess the flat earthers also have
that problem
again it's uh it's like religion you
have all these different religions this
guy
believes in mohammed the other guy in
gautama and so on you know and what are
you going to say
oh i've got the truth you got the lie
i'm sorry
oh yeah but again it comes up to a lot
of points like cigarettes
for the longest time people thought the
cigarettes were healthy but then
the the belief changed like okay we're
starting to kind of you see more effects
yeah you'll start coughing your lungs
out yeah maybe it's not that healthy
buddy
okay uh brings in the issue of
observation okay another issue that's
very touchy in
the word science at first it seems
rational that facts and observation have
no place in science at all
and that science is only rational
explanations but without observation
what is there to explain oh very
important question because
this word observation is a killer people
think that observation has something to
do with science
so i'm going to give you three arguments
i have more arguments i'm just going to
give you three arguments of why the word
observation should be eliminated from
the lexicon
of science completely we don't need the
word observation at all here's the first
one okay here's the first argument i
don't know how you define it though
uh well that's i've been to part of that
okay here's the definition of what
observation means uh so this is argument
number one
this is the wrong context for
observation in the religion of
mathematical
physics so-called science the word
observation is a synonym a
proof it's an it's a weapon that is used
against you
observation means i have proven my
theory and you have no say in the matter
you have to believe
it because we proved it through an
experiment and here's the
equation to verify our observation
the theory is now a fact deal with it
that's what observation means
okay so whenever you hear observation
they're trying to shove
a fact down your throat that's uh that's
a theory down your throat turned into
fact that's what it is
okay you have the theory of evolution
is that a fact well you'll have a lot of
these people saying well it's a fact
no it's not a fact it's a theory and
they say well theory is like a belief
and so they don't like the word theory
this you know it's been proven
what is it what have you been proven
proven you mean it turned into a fact
what is it fat for whom for you well in
fact means that it's a done deal like
like you can't contest it you can't
challenge it anymore because it's a fact
we've proven it
it's it's proof now it's fact it's it's
a done deal
and it's like you can't challenge it
because you know evolution is a fact
no no evolution is a theory there's
another theory that says god made
adam and eve right with a magic wand and
he put them on earth a lot of people
believe in that theory
and this guy says well i don't like that
theory yeah well yeah but
that's a fact for this guy and this is a
fact for you maybe the word fact
is better definitely no we need to get
rid of the word fact
proof observation because observation
means fact
proof means your theory turned into a
done deal that's what he will usually
when someone can't challenge fact
the one what i understand under the
notion fact is what mother nature knows
essentially what god knows to be true
yeah whatever that means it's what none
of us could
could really know for 100 she knows for
a fact yeah
what happened is it's in her file
cabinet
but it's kind of like like in in like
problem solving math
books where they have the answer on the
back god has that answer but we never
get that answer right
you can do you don't
you can you can throw ideas out there
and say well i think it's this the other
guys i think it's that and that's fine
but to say no no mine is the truth yours
is is not a truth mine is a fact
i turned my theory into a fact well this
guy has a different fact
it's just too wishy-washy it's not all
beliefs you can't talk about
you can't talk about knowledge you can't
talk about proof you can't talk about
fact
in science that all belongs to religion
why do we do experiments to get evidence
what do we do
why do we present evidence to persuade
the jury
religion or ourselves even yeah or
ourselves yeah right
but i mean what's the purpose of
evidence to persuade
that's what we use evidence for that's
why experiments
and evidence have nothing to do with
science we don't do
experiments in science i know people say
what are you saying bill
how can you say that yeah we don't do
experiments we explain them well because
you have to explain because you could do
logic with with
assumptions you don't really need yeah
i'm getting to that in a second but let
me give you an experiment here's an
experiment okay
there's an experiment i can do it
repeatable to make it very scientific
here it goes again okay
okay so what did uh what did i learn
that the pencil falls to the floor
do i know why can i explain the cause
that brought the pencil to the floor
do i know do i have particles pushing on
it do we have uh
strings pulling on it by doing an
experiment
i have not done science yet you didn't
see the angel it was
grabbing it yeah i can say that too and
i can and i can say that you know i can
say
uh it was angels and the guy said no
we've proven it was particles but none
of these theories are a fact
what does that mean is the one that's a
fact that's not sure one of those
theories is the fact but we'll never
know which one is the fact
mine is the one that's a fact always for
me
no you can't use knowledge fact or proof
not in science i like
fact because fact is like again the
answer
that mother nature yeah they're one of
the nationals we'll never know which one
the fact
is we can just like mother nature god
the devil
all those people know but we don't know
a lot of people know
but they're up there yeah i'll never see
them maybe when you get to the pretty
gates
okay here's argument number two is that
are those gonna be your first words was
i right
[Laughter]
see i knew it was a fact okay here's uh
now send me down i can prove it to
everyone else
okay here's argument number two stephen
hawking was a guru in black holes
stephen hawking never observed a black
hole in his life no one has to this day
stephen hawking what inferred that there
was
an unimaginable 0d object that mediated
unexplained uh cosmic phenomena stephen
hawking
simulated stars twirling around
and losing gas from the skins to this
zero d
entity okay therefore again the word
observe is used as a synonym of proof in
fact
you cannot challenge the black hole
hypothesis anymore today
someone already saw it so it has to be
real yeah you have to remember that the
black hole
uh has always been inferred indirectly
and they'll tell you that they have no
problem
telling you that they will you know all
these people like uh gentle the other
guy
they he won the nobel prize well one of
those the other one was um
uh what was the name roger penrose you
know they won the
nobel prize for what for inferring
indirectly that's what this paper say
that
they inferred indirectly that there is
some massive
object that we can't see that we can't
touch
that is zero dimensional that has all
this mass that's moving stars around but
by definition
you can't see a black hole so you say
even that's wrong because because then
you have stephen hawking says that you
have this light coming
out of there that black holes you know
uh
that uh when when it pulls a photon
the photon breaks into two virtual
particles one is the positron the other
one the electron
one is sucked in the other one flies out
i don't know why it flies out because
all the gravity should be pulling it in
sounds massless
but yeah but so no but a good example is
air
where no matter how what uh tools you
use to see air you can never see it you
can always just see its effects
yeah yeah yeah it's always inferred yeah
yeah
it's like it's a it's a theory that says
there are atoms here
and i'm breathing atoms that there are
these particles that are flying around
and it's a theory and the guy might say
well it's a fact
no it's not a fact it's a fact to you
because
right a proof that can't be challenged
and you say it's a fact no
you can't say it's a fact you're putting
a theory saying look let's assume there
are particles
called oxygen or whatever nitrogen and a
this gas that we can't see and i'm
breathing it and i pass my hand i can
touch it i can breathe it but i can't
see it
and so that's your explanation yeah but
it's an explanation it's nothing but an
explanation as soon as you say it's a
fact
well it's a fact to you because the
other guy says no these are spirits that
we're breathing
and what are you gonna say no and the
other guy's gonna say no it's energy or
who knows what i mean he can come up
with anything
and that's what he believes for him it's
not a fact that there are particles here
they say well that's an assumption and
he's right it's just an assumption
and you're using that assumption to
explain why you can breathe people don't
like that people don't like that we
should
believe this yeah it destroys it
destroys are argued
no but it doesn't sound right to say i
believe
there's particles going in my nose it's
like
you feel it yeah what do you mean belief
i can feel it but the other guy says no
it's it's spirits that's going into your
nose what are you going to say
that guy's a dumb ass obviously
for him it's a fact you know i
i'm sure i go to the uh jungles you know
maybe
some long-lost tribe out there that's
still in the stone age
and you'll say you know what is that
stuff you breathe the guy said oh
that's the spirit of my grandfather you
know what are you gonna say to the guy
you say no no look there are these
particles you call atoms
what do you explain to the guy the guy
believes in something else he for him
it's not a fact
and that's all there is uh all you can
do have an explanation a rational
explanation
and some people subscribe to it and some
people don't have some other
explanations
i really think people just don't like
the word belief yeah because it because
it means that oh you just have a belief
yeah it's not
well they pulled it out of your ass
that's what it sounds no no in fact
they have that in in the case of uh uh
what is it
evolution the religious folk come in and
they say well but it's just a theory
and that just upsets you what do you
mean
it's a fact uh evolution is a fact it's
it's just a theory
like say it's just a belief yeah but
what's wrong with that
because theory does not mean belief
theory means explanation yeah that's
different but once you define theory as
an
objective explanation then you have no
problem but as soon as you put in there
and say
it's a fact i turn my theory into a fact
ah then you'd run into trouble but again
i i just don't understand the
the reservation of using
the word belief like it doesn't enough
it means it's just your it's just
not enough it's not enough to say i
believe i'm alive
what's wrong with that i don't know
okay and here's the last one uh last
argument for that
okay if i can get this down here okay
and this is the uh
mafia uh principle of science
observation equal testimony equals
witness you can't introduce
witnesses in science it's what you do is
you follow
al capone there he said has the mafia
principle
kill the observer kill the witness no
witness
should reach the stand you're saying
logic can be done without
uh observations we do it all with
assumptions so
observers just muddy the water is that
the issue well let's put it this way we
have a blind man
okay now he has trouble using his eyes
what are we going to talk about with him
about the moon
on the other hand you tell the uh um
the blind man you say okay look there is
this moon that's going around the earth
okay and i don't know why and maybe he
can explain to you
why that moon goes around the earth
he never saw it he just reasoned in his
dark world
he never saw the moon and you just
explain to him
the observation though what you saw he
hasn't seen it
like uh stephen hawking never saw black
hole but he can reason it for you can
theorize it for you and give you an
objective explanation
that's where science stops so you're
saying in this case
he's taking your observations as
assumptions so like okay let's assume
there's a big thing up in the sky
let's assume we're a big rock what could
be the explanation
taking these assumptions what could be
the explanation for this phenomenon
of one ball going around the other and
that's the issue and you've held
strings before so it might be this yeah
for example
and we don't deal with observations we
deal with
assumptions the word is assumptions in
science in
science we have no observations we kill
the witness we
burn his eyes we don't want to observe
anything okay
observe means you're going to introduce
testimony witnesses
you're going to introduce what you saw
and imagine these people say
well we saw we they don't use the word
saw they use the word observed which is
very tricky
because they say we observed a photon
zipping by
and you say what do you mean you observe
the photon why did they use the word
observe because
it gives you that hint that hey we did
see it with our eyes
that's what a lot of people out there
appreciate common folk that's what they
understand they say oh they observed the
photon going by
i thought it was an assumption now these
people are making an assumption
that there is such a thing as a particle
called a photon which is not a particle
by the way
but they say they use the word observe
and people say well
the scientists observed it in the lab
who am i to question that
that's how they use they use it as proof
they use eyewitnesses
i'm giving you in my testimony you're
gonna doubt my testimony i'm a scientist
that's what they're saying that's why
the word observed should be eliminated
from science
we don't use the word observe we use
assumptions
and we do not need to observe anything
to
make a theory to explain something
objectively that's all
that science is in the end okay
uh another follow put something along
these lines
lots of questions uh along this line
uh scientists in science says putting
yourself
in the shoes of a scientist living at
just the dawn of powerful
microscopes what would you say about
looking into a glass and seeing these
animals
kind of like what robert hook did with
micrographia he just looked at stuff
through the microscope and found a lot
of stuff
even looked at tobacco plants and so on
well
this is the answer i give you i would
say that you should not call him a
scientist
it's premature he will be a scientist
when he can explain the mechanism
underlying what he observed
why did you call him a scientist so far
uh all he did was just
uh is it's just a lab boy he's just uh
go for doing
data collection for his master so for
all he did was god
he saw something is that science just
because he observed something
you know of observation is not science
obs
science is explain explain something
explain
what happened explain a mechanism
objectively so that i can understand it
not so that i believe it
so that i understand it and people will
have problems with that because they
want to introduce their religion
that's simple that's why you put it but
it
is off the rails when well because
people are not used to
explaining objectively people simply
want to tell their religion
they want to say well this is what i
believe this is i believe it because all
the scientists believe in it and they
proved it in the lab
that's the essentially the argument of
everybody out there and that's not
science that's known as religion in
science we say look let us assume
there's this
and this is my theory this is my
objective explanation for how this
took place for example magnetism for
example gravity
light electricity uh the workings of the
atom
so you're trying to explain something
objectively not so the person believes
so that the person understands the
mechanism then he can reach his own
conclusion
in his own dark basement you don't have
to influence him he'll reach his own
conclusion on his own based on his
upbringing
and education okay and
so here's another uh stars on the
galactic rim
travel is fast or faster than those in
the center so far that's
what a description so far you haven't
explained absolutely anything
oh you're saying i saw something here
well again the context here is
is this science is this observation uh
is observation science
the guys that says i observe he just
stated an observation yeah he says this
is what we say
yeah should we put a period there and
say okay we did science let's go go home
let's get our nobles
no so far you have a description there's
no question there's no explanation
right so this is just a description if
someone asks why
do the stars on the outside travel
faster than the center that is
a scientific question and the answer to
that would be also science
yeah because you would have to explain
objectively how that
magic trick is done i guess that's
implied that there that this is a
phenomenon to be explained
yeah but see they stop there and they
say oh i did science because i
found out that the stars you know and
the rim go as fast or faster
and then does this description qualify
as science just just there where we
stopped
it doesn't that's not science what we
have so far it's like saying
oh i saw the chair fall down was that
science
maybe maybe the explanation is why or
what caused the chair to fall down that
would be a more interesting question
what have you explained what have you
learned should we give you a nobel prize
for your observation
because that's what they do today they
give nobles to mathematicians for what
for discovering phenomena and describing
them with equations
that's what they think is science and so
this is where they give all these prizes
because they say oh that's science
now that's not science that's describing
something saying oh i found this
specific behavior in nature okay you
found it and scientific question i guess
it raises unless you explain something
whether
you just like you say i'm the first one
in the
first person in the world to see a
rhinoceros should i give you a noble for
that because you're the first one who
saw a rhinoceros
say oh i found this animal it's so weird
it's got this
horn and is that science just saying
i found a rhinoceros i discovered it i'm
the first one give me a noble
is that science no science is explaining
something
finding something tripping you know and
falling
and saying oh i tripped and fell i
observed
that's not science and that's what all
these people do they describe they
they discover some phenomena they
explain it
supposedly with particles which is not
an explanation partly because particles
are not particles
and then they say here's the description
a mathematical description here's the
equation they say okay give him a noble
that's that's what science is today and
all he did was persuade his peers
who think exactly like him to begin with
okay
this is also in observation he says see
doesn't mean just with your eyes
we have all kinds of machines that see
what we can't with our limited vision
okay so here's my answer uh can these
machines see the invisible intangible
mediators of light gravity and magnetism
there you have them on the bottom okay
you have an atom you have light which is
known as an electromagnetic wave you
have a magnetic field
there uh can these machines
see these invisible intangible
things if these are things is a field a
thing
can you see a field can a machine see a
field
or can it just uh see the effects see
the effects like iron filings
okay and so if so
what uh have the machines draw
have the machines draw these invisible
and tangible meteors for us i want the
machine
not that you program it but for the
machine to do it all in fly itself to
see if it can
uh infer or whatever if it's saw
it hasn't doesn't you have to infer it
says that this is what i saw
yeah can a machine do that you just see
the picture of light well you know a lot
of these machines
like you know you take uh like a photo
multiplier and i i use these machines uh
when i worked
as an engineer at amd and what uh what
they do
is they're already programmed their
algorithm inside it
is already designed to detect any blip
any any frequency anything as a as a
particle so it just counts particles and
you're saying well
obviously you know it's counting
particles right no it's counting
something that it doesn't understand it
just
treats it as a particle because that's
what's been programmed into the machine
and so they say
okay now you have like you have a higher
intensity that means you have more
particles
oh is that what really happened or is
that what you programmed into the
machine
i mean you know it's garbage in garbage
out whatever you put in that's what
you're going to get out
but that's been programmed into the
photo multiplier
okay and you have a lot of stuff like
that out there you know
you have an ellipsometer and it tells
you the thickness of a
layer say of oxide or whatever layer of
film
and it's already programmed
to go in there and convert uh
light through this uh table known as a
refractive index
and it just says well light went slower
over here
did it go slower or is that just an
algorithm that you programmed into the
ellipsometer
so that you know when it gets a little c
300
000 kilometers per second which should
be wrong anyways because that's only in
in outer space not here where you have
air and air travels slower
and that goes through this film of glass
for example right and that says well
it's
1.45 times the speed of light
oh what do you mean d right i'm sorry
the light the speed of light divided by
1.45 1.5
whatever so it's so they're saying ah no
the speed of light here
is uh 200 000 or or or
less than three hundred thousand
kilometers per second well
is that simply is is that simply because
we programmed in
into the ellipsometer or is that what
light really does does it slow down
and then if it slows down why does it
speed up later on again okay
so we gotta hear him on that part yeah
uh
you put energy into it and start
speeding up after it leaves the glass
yeah so again these are uh all ad hoc
type of things that we program into the
machines okay
okay a couple more issues here
also related to science and some
geometry and so on
okay here it says in magnetic levitation
of your body you would feel it
as weightlessness and he says touch
weightlessness if anything is the
opposite of touch means you're not
touching anything
uh what touched you what came in
physical contact with you please draw it
i want to know what touched you if
you're saying that weightlessness is
touch
just draw whatever touched you what does
he mean weightlessness is touch
well he's saying that if you're floating
out there like a an astronaut in outer
space
he says that's touch what do you mean
that's ty what's touch yeah that's what
i mean i'm saying it's the opposite of
touch i would say
weightlessness if anything is the
opposite of touch but if you think
something touched the astronaut please
draw it i want to know
what thing touched the astronaut out
there that's what you got to explain
okay or justify before we can believe
your
theory here we can see the shape of
magnetism with demonstrations such as
you showed using iron filings okay this
is what i showed the other day
let me get it up here
give me a second here
okay and here you can see what's
happening okay
yeah yeah yeah and here you see a magnet
and they uh
just uh they make all the iron filings
bounce on some kind of trampoline of
some kind
and you can see they're the shapes that
are happening okay
that are uh being created by this
invisible thing we call a magnetic field
but as you can see the iron filings are
picked up one
at a time closer to the magnet
okay you can see one at a time they're
going in there something is moving in
that
region we call a magnetic field you have
to identify
what is pulling on a single iron filing
what is pulling on one iron filing
that's what you got to
identify oh you're saying pulling yeah
i'm saying
okay you can do pull i don't care if you
do push ex please draw what's pulling or
pushing on each
not on the whole thing i want one iron
filing i want you to show me
what physical object is coming in
contact with one iron filing what if
it's invisible
well yeah it is invisible and tangible
but this file says that this shows what
uh
here's his comment he says
he says we can see the shape of
magnetism
with demonstrations such as this no no
don't tell me about the shape of
magnetism tell me what
what pulls or pushes on one iron filing
that's the answer that we need okay i
can't show you because it's invisible
but i mean he's got to show me what came
in contact what does he propose
what does he propose an invisible thing
well i don't care it's a thing
draw it make it visible you can't make
it yeah make it visible for for my eyes
i want to see what gaming content
or are you going to do it with spirits
are you going to say there's a spirit
that's pushing or pulling on the
on one iron filing well i guess the
point is it's invisible so you can't
draw it it's like drawing air
no no you you can you can draw air
because you make an assumption you say
this is what i propose
air is now you draw and you say this is
what i think
uh if it had color this is what it would
look like right if
if it had visibility this is what it
would look like that's what we need for
you to do
with whatever's pulling on one iron
filing don't talk about a field don't
talk to me about
uh you know what pulls on the the shape
of the magnetic field
tell me what's pulling on the shape of
the thing that's pulling on one iron or
pushing on one iron filing
that's the issue that's what you got to
draw and again
what we saw is iron filings moving we
did not see the thing that moved
each iron filing towards the magnet and
formed patterns with many
iron filings please draw the shape of
the object that came in contact with
one arm piling and moved it
okay remember uh that's that's what uh
good old james maxwell came up with and
so did
for that matter michael faraday who
played around with magnus and
electricity
these fellows reached the same
conclusion that was in the 19th century
unfortunately people forgot but james
maxwell said it very clearly
there is matter in motion that's what a
field is
matter in motion something is moving in
there something's
doing something one at a time there's
there's happening
it's pulling or pulling or pushing you
want to do push no problem i say it's
pull
but what it's doing is one iron filing
at a time is coming closer to the magnet
you got to explain what came in contact
with the iron filing
you cannot say nothing came in contact
with the iron fan because i can't see or
touch it
now then you're putting angels you're
putting spirits in that same space
you're saying
mother nature does this with spirits
that's all you said
so you're a religious person because
you're introducing spirits you're saying
there's nothing there you're saying like
air you have to give whatever magnetism
is shape
so that we can see oh okay so it's like
a rope that's doing it or i don't know
it's balls hitting
each iron filing and throwing it to you
or something how do you explain
air to someone i mean if you want to try
to smell it more or less logically
like i said maybe to a pygmy or whatever
out there in the jungle well you would
say look
let's assume that this thing has here
is made out of atoms these are the atoms
okay there's
these molecules a bunch of balls yeah
they're all in there
and we're saying that this is floating
around for whatever reason and we're
this is what we're breathing so you
would explain a phenomenon in that way
can we see
the the iron the atoms no you draw them
and you say this is what i think is
in that invisible region and that's the
same thing we do with light we say
what is light well some people believe
it's a series of particles
so what do they do they draw a bunch of
particles other people draw a wave and
they say well i think it's a magnetic
uh and uh electric field they go at 90
degrees they draw this you know this
the famous field uh you know magnetic
electromagnetic
you're turning something which is
invisible you're making it visible so
that you can
give your explanation someone can follow
what you're saying do the same thing
with gravity
do the same thing with magnetic field
just tell me what physical
objects in there draw it don't tell me
draw it put a put a picture
an image so we know what what came in
contact with one
iron filing don't talk about the field
we'll extrapolate oh that yeah yeah
that the field has shape now no we know
the field has shape because we see it in
the iron filing tell me what came in
contact
what shape what thing came in contact
with one arm finally
and then we'll know if you know okay
then we can use about knowledge
the shape of please predict well the
shape of the
the amalgamation of all the things is a
different question yeah
we want to know what what came in one
don't make it complicated we'll make it
easy for you just
draw what came in contact with one arm
finally and we'll be done with this
happily to the right
and here's what a field is a field is a
region of space
well this fellow he did it the other day
as a field is a region of space he put
the stuff up there
and and what is a field well each point
is associated with
a quantity so what is a field a bunch of
quantities a bunch of numbers
and the static field all uh uh at any
given point in space is a number
and that's what uh good old nick lucid
uh good old curly there that's what he
put
that's the reference he gave and that's
what good nick
lucid put in his uh site he put a bunch
of numbers he says that's what a field
is
so you can't say that a bunch of numbers
does anything
and this will continue and say well
those represent atoms represent
yeah yeah yeah yeah because he's got to
represent him so so that's what i'm
saying here you have two magnets okay
the little
uh circles there okay and there okay
these are magnets right okay are you
saying that in between here
there are atoms is that what pulled them
together is that what the field
represents a bunch of atoms that are in
here that are pulling these together or
or maybe on the outside what is bringing
these two
magnets together are you saying nothing
is there because you can't see or touch
it
is that why it's nothing then you're
putting spirits you're doing black magic
that's all you're doing
and so you can't say the field did it
because a field is a concept
a bunch of numbers that's what this guy
said is we kind of crap on the word
represent
a lot but isn't aren't we using
representation when we
give color to the invisible objects
we're making an assumption
not a representation we're making an
assumption we're saying let us assume
let us assume air is a bunch of balls
right that's not a representation
right you're saying let us assume we're
gonna make an assumption that's why you
don't say
i believe because that's religion i've
proven that's religion
you just say let us assume so that you
understand
what i'm gonna explain then you're okay
but as soon as you say i've proven it
it's a fact
give me my noble then we got religion
okay
okay uh a couple more questions noble
guys do you
no no because they're all it's uh just
politics
that's a club it's politics okay uh
so i put here the entire language
so-called science is corrupt
has been distorted beyond recognition by
all mentally [ __ ]
authors who run and have full uh control
over the world of math
okay that's the same they use euphemisms
figures of speech
okay and so on and so forth that's
essentially my conclusion
particles are not particles spin does
not mean spin it's not spinning like a
top
you know i talked about that orientation
it's an orientation
they don't even know they don't have a
definition for the word spin but every
time they use the word spin they
insinuate that it's what a top does
and that's not what spin is because what
does half spin mean what does
uh three half spin mean what is it what
is this nonsense three corners
they're giving you numbers to spin i
spin the top and oh that's a three
quarter spin
so yeah they have all these euphemisms
straight is not straight when they
say straight they mean rectilinear
because they're talking about motion and
not about something that is straight
flat is not flat and so on they have
euphemism
infinity we just talked about that
infinite and infinity
there's no such monster in physics in
science so you can't use these words
they use all these words because they
come from mathematics
that's why they've introduced them into
physics you can't use these terms in
physics i thought the words would help
but then
no it just confused everybody worse
because people say well they they
observed no they didn't observe anything
you can't observe anything in the real
world in the invisible world all you can
do is
make an assumption but when they say
observed it's like i saw i saw the
particle
i saw the the virtual particle for
example right
okay last two questions then we'll open
up the floor
uh like two or three questions okay so
it was good
okay so let's go with this gravity is
the same is in the same configuration as
magnetism
that's what the spell says the shape of
magnetism around the planet
well there you have it does the
gravitational field look like a magnetic
field
first of all you have the magnetic field
in the north pole at least you know
you can see that they go in and they
come out the south pole maybe it's the
other way around who cares
the point here is that that pattern
there formed by the magnetic field of
the earth
does not match the gravitational field
of the earth which is
all towards the center so you can't say
it's the same configuration
gravity is not magnetism you got this
from the electric universe they believe
in this stuff that it's electricity or
magnetism
these people are insane at the center of
a plan is zero gravity environment point
source zero point yeah and that's
different than what you have
for magnetism we can see that it's at
see we can see
we can see that it's acting the same way
as magnetic attraction with a cavendish
experiment absolutely not
and there you say it i don't need to go
beyond this gravitational field is not
the same thing as a magnetic field and
the effects have different shapes
they have different this should be basic
this should be kindergarten stuff but
we just saw with the iron filing some
people just wrong they didn't all go
in they kind of did this weird yeah and
and that's not what magnum
gravity does is always directional and
that's why they had to invent
negative gravity you know you have yeah
yeah because you have you have
just push no no no no you got to
understand this
what is what is dark energy dark energy
is negative gravity
what you have is gravity should pull
everything in so we had this
big explosion known as the big bang
right 14 billion years ago so
everything's expanding you say well why
doesn't all that get pulled back by
gravity
i mean have all this matter that should
be pulling at each other and so they
said ah
that's because we have uh this negative
gravity and
we're going to call it dark energy which
is pushing everything out
against the gravitational pull of mass
that's what dark energy is and that's
what they're studying these
these bean brains that call themselves
mathematical physicist
that's what they do they study dark
energy which is allegedly
negative energy if energy if gravity is
pushing out and that's the positive
gravity the negative energy
the negative gravity means pulling in
and that's what dark energy
uh is the opposite of uh of gravity i i
said it in reverse it should be yeah
yeah
right you lost me okay
they call that negative gravity they
call it dark energy that's what pushes
everything out
that's what they they invented uh the
opposite of gravity
anti-gravity
last question and then we'll open up the
floor here
where do you get these questions like
the ones that you put these are from
last week people who
put comments uh well they put comments
in the uh video
okay last one here objects
three-dimensional is a requirement
in physics he says that an object has to
be three-dimensional okay
uh we don't know what the what
definition he's got for three
dimensional uh
i guess it's that one down below because
that's the one he put okay
and again the physics definition of
object in wikipedia originated from
physics dictionaries
absolutely not what does the wikipedia
say
in common usage it doesn't say the
physicist said no it says in common
usage
they don't have a definition for the
word object in all of science in all of
physics
why because they don't use objects in
mathematical physics and those are the
people who are in charge of so-called
physics
they don't care about objects so there
is no definition of the word object
because they never realize that you
can't do physically without objects
and they don't because they're going to
be doing equations they're not going to
be doing moving objects
in physics with the shape with the
length of the object they do the physics
with the location of the object but they
don't do anything with the object itself
and that's one issue the other one is
that you know they don't give any
importance to physical interpretations
they call that philosophy
they get a little bit because they they
at some point they throw
their two cents no no but when when when
you put them against the corner you say
hold it that's
irrational we're not supposed to take it
literally or they say well that's
philosophy anyway that's the position
he thinks i'm being literal it's a
representation obviously
and then again uh yeah what's the
non-representation of it is
is is that what an object is a
collection of matter here you have a
collection of apples
is is that an object a collection of
apples
pile of apples yeah is that an object it
could be doesn't look like an
object you know it's a bunch of apples
and
ah is light mediated by an object we
need an answer to that
is there an invisible intangible object
in there that mediates light
and there you see a whole bunch of
lights crisscrossing do the little
photons
ricochet they bounce against each other
and pop out
like when you put two um hoses
you know water hoses against each other
you know you'll see the drops
hitting each other and bouncing out is
that what you see with light all the
photons are really small
yeah and they have all this uh these
weird explanations
where they um where they um turn
the photon into a particle anti-particle
pair
that recombine again and turn into a
virtual photon
that's how they explain all this now
they have to dodge the other particles
yeah yeah you said well they do it
they're about to hit each other turn
into non-particle
going through and then they turn back
they do it with finding diagrams it's
all
nonsense all math is just saying well
look they split up they turn into
a particle anti-particle pair
then they recombine turned into a
virtual photon again and they continue
and then the detector detects that
and so they through this rigamarole they
try to give you a physical
or a semblance of a physical
interpretation
and and you say well what caused
what caused the photon to split up
into proton uh uh positron and electron
pair
now you're just asking extra questions
yes they never explained that
it does it did and what is that that's
magic that's just
you know magic wand you gotta use magic
at some point don't you yeah yeah so do
i
here's my magic wand abracadabra but
at some point during a theater you have
to say it just does don't you
well again science should be assumption
explain the theory objectively so that a
person understands we're done with
science what continues
then is religion belief your opinion you
take it home
you believe in this one the other guy
believes in the other theory okay
how did the window break this guy said
well a dog jumped through the window the
other guy said no it was a baseball bat
the other guy said no hit it with a
crowbar
so you have all these different theories
of how the window got broken
and all you do is explain it rationally
or objectively and say look this is what
i think happened here the other
guy says this is how i think it happened
and then everybody
leaves the scene and everyone can
believe in whatever they want to believe
that's religion the objective
explanation is the only part that
concerned science you want to get the
questions let's go to the questions
um go slowly sometimes you skip too much
no i don't skip anything
and people get get upset oh you skipped
my question sometimes they asked the
same thing like seven times
or something that's like this i'll get
it
okay
[Music]
oh this is talking about this isn't so
much a question but it's a comment on
knowledge okay um usually you know
things saying
if all things go as expected there are
always random things that happen
but it's not that doesn't make you wrong
it just implies there are things you
were not aware of
yeah but again for example the comment
hitting earth before the
pen yeah but that's why we should not
use the word uh knowledge or the word
wrong
because wrong is an opinion wrong and
right just means you you
qualified it you suddenly gave it a
qualification that was unwarranted not
in science
and what is knowledge knowledge means
that again the way we define it is
that you can predict something is going
to happen because that's how you prove
your knowledge to the professors or
whatever
you want you want to show something to
someone you run an experiment you say
i can tell you what's going to happen if
i do this experiment
then you have knowledge if you can
predict it without
error but you can't because there's
always things you're not right that
you're not aware of there's many things
happening out there
the variables that you cannot uh you
know factor in because you're not aware
of them
like you know i'm saying okay look i'm
going to let go of this pencil
right and i let go of it 10 times and
say look it always falls to the floor
and suddenly i let go of it and stand in
the air
how did that happen and it turns out
that i tricked you i fooled you i had
two magnets you know
pulling on the metal you know inside it
and it
i just turned the magnets on the
electromagnets on it stays in the air
and you didn't know okay so you did not
know that it was going to fall to the
floor you did not predict
we cannot know not even god can predict
anything um
as a side note these questions and
comments might be more meaningful if i
do them in the moment
i don't want to like side track us
anyways
okay saying like for the next time might
be better do this real time
um do you understand that the
basis of psychopaths is thinking love is
a concept
have you done the rice experiment or do
you just ridicule it
uh i really killed it right what's the
racing i have no idea
but uh love love is a concept what is it
a physical object
is is love a physical object are you
saying that you can draw a picture of
love
that it's got shape you know that
because that's what a physical object is
and there's only two types of words one
is
uh concept and the other one the other
group is objects and so it's either an
object or a concept if you know of a
third category hey you should bring it
on
in his latest experiment emoto prepared
three jars of rice he wrote i love you
on the first one you idiot
on the other one and ignored the third
one after a month the first jar of rice
went sour
and there was mold on the rice in the
second and third jar
so you that's that's a that's a no for
you okay
nonsense so you're a psychopath yeah i'm
a psychopath
no doubt about it uh sidestep my
question again once again katie
what is there to explain without first
an observation
yeah you don't need observation you make
an assumption yeah
uh you don't need to observe again
einstein did not observe space time uh
hawking did not
observe uh black hole and that means
that they cannot
give you a physical interpretation for
how
what's happening to these stars out
there that move around they're giving
you a physical interpretation i
i don't agree with them because they say
there's a singularity
full of mass but that's their assumption
they're saying well we can
we can describe it mathematically and
that's our physical interpretation that
there is
something out there did they observe no
they observed
they observed the sun running a star
going around in circles
they did not observe the black hole
that's an assumption that's an inference
and the same with light you see light do
something
and are you going to say that there's
nothing there there's no physical object
there
so you make an assumption you say well
let us assume that there's an
electromagnetic wave or there's a
let's assume that light consists of a
series of particles that travel in a
rectilinear
uh fashion then you make an assumption
oh yeah that doesn't doesn't mean that
you either believe or that
you need to observe you did not observe
light the mediator the question goes
before that they're saying
how are you even going to ask a question
if you didn't even observe something
and again the problem with the word
observe is that they treat it as proof
first no no that is important it's
important let let me
go through those steps here so that this
file understands
first of all it's used as the word proof
that's what observe means so that's the
first reason you got to remove the word
observe
but you say i need to observe you can
only observe what you can see
visible we're talking about the
invisible did you observe the invisible
did you observe the intangible
did you observe the the mediator of
gravity
so so can you say that if i'd let go of
the pencil
okay i can observe the pencil or
observing did i observe gravity yeah but
without even observing a phenomenon how
can you ask a question
again that's not science science is not
the observation part and we don't use
the word observe
in the scientific method we say let us
assume
because you may have to make an
assumption for the mediator of gravity
you can't say
i observe gravity no no that's not the
point the point that is at the point
remember that the point is
is i guess is asking the question
science because when someone says
oh the moon goes around the sun it goes
around the earth for example well that's
an observation
how can you even ask the question if you
didn't see the moon go around the sun
yeah but the question here it's it's
very tricky because you did not observe
the
gravitational mechanism and so people
use the word observe and say
well i observe what did you observe you
observed the moon going around the earth
but what you're trying to explain is
gravity you you're trying to explain
the mechanism of gravity you cannot say
that you observed gravity so
you don't need the word observation at
all you just make an assumption
you mean you don't need the word
observation to explain something right
and
you don't even need observations where
in the scientific method do you find the
word observation in the rational
scientific method
in in religion yes uh what mathematical
physics is do
uh they use the word observation because
they're gonna say that we observed
uh the photon did they observe the
photon i don't think that's the
that is that is it is it's not
again like for example when we're
talking about magnetism yeah the shape
of magnetism
yeah we're seeing the shape of magnetism
not not not magnetism itself we're
seeing the effects
but this is the issue people get
confused between the invisible stuff and
the visible
yeah but just talking about the visible
part here we see the shape of the iron
filings right
so we're seeing something i didn't
observe anything for example
i didn't observe anything i want to talk
about this
hypothetical situation of a star on the
other side of the universe did i see
that i observe
anything no i make an assumption let us
assume there's a star on the other side
of the universe let us assume there's a
moon there's an asteroid there's a
common
i can assume anything i don't need to
observe absolutely anything in science
you're saying you could do science
without any bearing on
whatever i can make a hypothetical i
could make a hypothetical situation
as long as it follows logically from a
from b then you're doing so i'm
explaining the mechanism not what i
observed
not the observation but i'm explaining a
mechanism what caused
the this thing to happen going back to
the blind guy if someone explains
and i explains but it gives you these
assumptions there's a rock going out
around another rock
that guy doesn't have to see anything
but he's still going off your
observation but you're saying that that
observation is irrelevant he could have
just come up with this
he could he could have invented a rock
going around not another rock
and the blind guy has to say well what
could be the explanation let me give you
another forensic another example
ets you know they came in the past and
they built the pyramids
did we observe that we observed how the
klingons came and built these pyramids
no
you see a pyramid but you see a pyramid
you see a pyramid but you did not
observe
the mechanism of how the how the pyramid
was built
so you suddenly you crash you bump your
nose against a pyramid
and now you have to explain did you
observe how the pyramid was built
and so you make an assumption say let us
assume there are extraterrestrials the
klingons they came here
two thousand three thousand four
thousand years ago and they built the
pyramids so you make an assumption but
you did not see how they built it you
did not see
because an observation means you saw it
over time
and you saw how it was built and you say
i observed it no you did not observe you
just
saw a wall okay but going off of where
you're going off what you're saying
you could do science with imaginary
stuff that has nothing to do with
reality
what if i talk about dragons what if i
talk about
god i mean did i observe god make humans
you can do science with dragons all i
need to do is
understand what the guy's proposing so
the guy says let us assume that god
exists that there is a goddamn the
magician you know the guy's got a magic
wand well you know what it is
yeah okay and he took some a little bit
of clay he put it together he blew
and spit on it that's not what i heard
he didn't do all that and suddenly
adam and eve came into being okay did he
did anyone observe any of that no he's
making a hypothetical assumption
he's saying let us assume that god is
there and he made man we didn't see any
of that we did not observe we just see
humans and you can say well i saw a
human yeah i mean
what does that have to do with anything
what does observation of a human
you bumped against a human bumped
against the wall you don't know how the
wall was built
so no observation has nothing at all to
do with science
observation is only a a fancy way of
introducing
testimony that's all it is we can see
the shape of magnetism
i guess talking about the iron filings
yeah isn't that your definition of
object that which has shape no that's
not the shape because
shape has to be shape has to be static
and what you have there is something
moving what did
james maxwell says say he said it's
matter in motion what you have to do is
stop
stop the matter in motion and we'll see
if those iron filing i mean if you could
do that right
if you could stop the the threads from
spinning which is
my theory there wouldn't be any
magnetism because you don't have the
mechanism to pull on those iron filings
and so the the question now is put to
you
please make visible please make visible
make
observable the thing that came in
contact with one
iron filing then you'll have an object
then then we can follow your
presentation otherwise you're just doing
it with spirits
you're doing black magic is an invisible
intangible
physical mechanism double rope single
thread
backed without observation experiment
invoking spirit's religious beliefs
yeah yeah we do without observation and
it's got nothing to do with religious
belief because it's not a belief it's an
assumption it's known as an
assumption you say let us assume we're
guessing
yeah it's a guess it's a proposal you're
saying let us assume
that the invisible stuff out there in
the universe is mediated
by a thread or by a rope or by whatever
that's an assumption just like
quantum mechanics makes an assumption
that or classical mechanics makes an
assumption that there are particles
and they say let us assume there are
particles out there discrete particles
and that's how they base their
explanations and i'm doing the same
thing i'm saying let us assume there's a
thread there's a rope
it's got nothing to do with belief it's
a proposal it's an assumption you know
what assumption is
what's the difference between
hypothetical and theoretical is the em
rope theoretical or hypothetical
hypothesis in rational science not in
the religion of mathematical physics not
in a religion or what they call science
today
in rational science in true science
genuine science
hypothesis only includes the objects
the definitions and the initial scene
theory
is the explanation of a mechanism one
has nothing
hypothesis has nothing at all is the em
rope theoretical or hypothetical
the the electromagnetic rope is a
hypothesis not a theory because
there is no theory called uh rope this
is a rope
okay this is a rope and this is an
object
and so uh we're not talking about we're
not talking about a theory yet
we're just saying we're presenting the
mediator
for light and for gravity which is this
invisible intangible
thing that has shape right that's what a
thing is
and with that we're going to explain the
mechanism i think the problem is an
ordinary species are used
interchangeably
theoretically hypothetically yeah yeah
yeah
uh do you understand your big joke to
the engineering
scientific physics community yeah it's
mutual
half of the world half of the world
laughs at the other half
uh what is there to explain without
first an observation yeah i guess we
went into that yeah uh if humans and
other creatures lose their genetic
diversity eventually
how living things started with a lot of
it
i i explained that with a graph the
other day
uh if you look at my previous video i
i covered that issue you have that when
uh
let me explain a few words i don't have
the graph here to show you but
if um if you look at a new species it
branches off usually from some other
animal
normally okay so it gets isolated in a
different region of the planet
one example is the neanderthals uh
what happens they migrated as far as i'm
concerned
their forefathers really you go back all
the way to a
man of heidelberg and even before then
homo erectus there was some kind of
creature two-legged
creature eight hundred thousand years
ago in england
okay and if you go there you'll find
these
these uh prove these um
what is it evidences these pieces of
evidence they found a
uh footprint they found some elephant
bones they said who hunted these who
burned these
well they said some kind of human that
was there uh
at least eight hundred thousand years
ago and that had to be the
range of homo erectus uh homo
heidelbergensis
who were the forefathers of neanderthal
okay so neanderthal
came out of these uh these folks
how did he come into being well at some
point neanderthal branched out
branched out the main line heidelberg
died
and what you have now is man of
neanderthal
now when he comes out he he goes into a
region which is totally different than
what his forefathers had
and what happens now this uh neanderthal
gets used to the cold
um he had no clothes and so he developed
certain
um genes or or some of the genes
pop up that have to live in the new
environment
which is different than what man who
came out of africa assuming that's what
happened right
uh who comes out of africa in a milder
climate
he doesn't have to fight against that so
hit other genes develop
in his world so these guys are different
why because they had to
cope with different environments and
what happens you take that
thousands of years into the future but
they're both losing genetic development
no no
at first they gained genetic diversity
because uh we have this selection going
on because of the
climate the the animals they hunt maybe
or
are hunted by you know uh they have to
live in different environments because
of that they develop different maybe
once closer to the sun
in the sense that you know not
like if you're in a higher latitude what
do you have you have um
uh maybe less ozone or whatever you know
there are different climatic
conditions my point here is the
following when a species
go gets isolated in an environment all
it can do at the beginning
from the mother branch is gain uh
genetic diversity it goes up
yeah it goes up because you're fighting
against a new environment and then once
you settle down more or less then
it only can come down and after that you
can't gain
genetic diversity you can only lose it
until you have
almost no genetic diversity left which
is which is
yeah which is the state of humanity
today we are all clones of each other
from a genetic point of view so it's not
there's not that much so it's not that a
species start off with a lot and it just
kept going down
and down it's like these like yeah it
goes first uh genetic diversity
increases then it
starts uh getting singular gets used and
especially diseases diseases are though
are the
sifter of genes because
once you conquer a disease that disease
can no longer affect your species
and we are the products of thousands of
years first of
uh founders effect followed by
population bottlenecks
and that constant process is what made
us today
that's why we're all the same that's why
japanese is equal to you
genetically not because they married in
with us but because
their grandfathers passed through the
same diseases i guess a good example is
like
10 of you survive a certain uh disease
extreme case everyone after that comes
from those 10 percent
right and and so we don't have to marry
a japanese or
or a white man like me uh an african
in order to enrich our genetic pool
because their grandfathers and the
grandfathers of the orientals and so on
they all went through the same diseases
that's the
that's the sifter we're all the same
we're all the same because of that we
passed all through the same diseases
except for coping oh we're going through
that one now
but that's also global yeah um also
would atoms look different on the edge
of the universe then closer to the
center where there would be more em
ropes arriving to them
from more directions yeah that's a big
question that we've dealt with a lot uh
we've dealt with that in the past but we
didn't have to observe the center of the
we didn't observe it okay no observation
we didn't we didn't observe the end of
the edge of the universe but we can
still try to explain what happened
well i think they would there there's uh
we
we're still having finished uh debating
that one completely we're still crack
trying to crack that egg
i say they look like tear drops on the
edge of the like a hydrogen atom would
look more like a teardrop at the edge of
of the universe because all the ropes
that makes it would be coming from one
direction
this is my explanation okay and again
it's not final i just want you to
get an idea where i'm coming from with
that the atoms at the edge
completely at the edge of the universe
we're thinking about maybe there's a
galaxy the last galaxy
uh the last star the last planet so so
to speak think of it in those terms okay
and what happens is uh what would you
see at the edge of the earth today well
you you see the edge of the universe
because what what happens at the edge of
the earth is you have a magnetic field
so the edge of the universe is not
filled with atoms
the edge of the universe is swept by
magnetic fields which are threads
magnetic field is just a bunch of
threads that are twirling around that's
what a magnetic field is that's what
those
lines of force are they're just threads
physical threads otherwise you gotta
explain the lines of force
what are those lines of force and they
say well those are we just you put them
in their
ad hoc to express presentations yeah
something's pushing
is more than representation something is
pulling on this and you're saying that's
just a representation
line of force we know that because we
throw iron families they line up yeah
what's doing it but then what's doing
what's what's forcing the iron filing to
line up what comes in contact with one
iron filing that's what you got to
identify if you can't identify that
you're not a scientist
next question no no no you're
sidestepping again
einstein saw the earth and the sun and
explained
with the with the general relativity
newton saw the apple
and the earth and explained you need to
assume about what you can already see
well
i talked about that the other day newton
did not have an explanation so no
newton never had an explanation he said
fingo non
hypothesis meaning i have no hypothesis
meaning
in in rational language i have no theory
i have no explanation for how mother
nature does this
especially when he was a particle man he
believed in particles so he said i
cannot explain it with particles how
how the earth rose around the sun how
the moon rose around the earth he could
not explain it
einstein did not explain it he gave us
the most irrational thing he could come
up with he says time is warped
that's what he said time is war that's
the
wall that comes up against the skin of
the earth and prevents the earth from
flying away
that's what he explained is that an
explanation is that a rational
explanation to say time is warped
at best it's a description not an
explanation at all but
for sure it's not an explanation a
rational explanation that's the physical
interpretation einstein's going to give
so now there is no explanation from
einstein or newton
that passes rationality you do not
understand the question at all
you see the moon and the earth they go
around each other so in science you put
a rope or whatever invisible to explain
i guess he's saying we we only explain
things that we
notice in real life observation always
comes first
the observation comes before the
question i guess is what he said you
cannot you cannot explain
invisible stuff no no but he's saying he
cannot serve
i guess he's going in before that he's
saying we couldn't even have questions
yeah we can we can't have questions i i
i can tell you what's happening at the
edge of the universe i've never been
there but i can imagine it
and i can visualize it and i can give
you an explanation but aren't you
extrapolating from things you've already
seen
you can go as far as you want i've seen
the the the pyramid i have not seen
observation means over time observation
not me
doesn't mean that i bumped against the
wall i have to explain how the wall was
was made that's what observation means i
have to put the
every frame in the film i guess to the
extreme to the that's an observation you
can't say
i observed the pyramids you had to
observe the pyramid to explain it no
the issue here is you have to you have
to observe the construction
of the pyramid not observe the pyramid
that's called c
not observation observation is over time
many frames of the film so you cannot
say you observe the pyramid
i guess to the extreme case if we were
all uh
blind and had no senses would we have
any
so would we have any questions you can
imagine but you can only imagine because
you have senses i guess is the point
it doesn't matter because the issue here
is i did not see
god make adam and eve i can still
imagine it
and i can still talk about it and i can
still propose it
i didn't have to observe god i didn't
have to observe adam and eve being made
i can make a hypothetical situation
you're the guy who doesn't understand
what is science's relative
relevance to the natural world if
science may as well be
about totally imaginary objects
it's not imaginary objects you got the
word imaginary
you're talking about imaginary it's not
imagine there's no such thing as
imaginary object there are objects and
there are there are
concepts so uh which one is it is it an
object does it have shape
or or does it not have shape in which
case it's a concept
so if i put a dragon a dragon has shape
it's an object it's not an imaginary
object we don't
we don't say that's a red object and
that's a big object we don't use
adjectives in front of the word
object that's where the problem is an
object is an object as an object that
which has shape
an angel is an object it's not a concept
it's not a
an abstraction an angel is known as an
object why because it has wings and has
a little
plate on his head and he's holy i can
draw an angel for you
i can show you a picture of an angel i
can draw a heart i cannot draw love
that's why
love is a concept do all our assumptions
that we make come from
past experiences
uh i don't know about i have no
experience with the edge of the universe
sorry i don't know what at the edge of
the universe looks like i can only
visualize and make an assumption about
the edge of the universe
was i ever there no but based on things
you've seen before i guess
you could take that as far as you went
again no but
but they're wrong or wrong wrong we make
an assumption assumption is not an
observation
observation is testimony we don't use
testimony in science
don't confuse the word observation with
assumption
assumption is something different than
observation some people argue that
humans can't really eat plants
plants were eaten as slave foods what
well i don't know okay i'll pass on that
one
some humans can't eat plants uh
so now observation becomes important in
irrational science
i don't know if there's a question yeah
we don't use the word observation
observation is religious people who want
to introduce testimony
that's the way we see it the word
observation means proof the guy is not
talking about observation he says we've
proven
we've seen we've observed the photon
that's what they're saying taken to the
extreme
saying you could say that robots like a
program can do logic
even though it never has no senses it
has no senses what do you mean
when uh when a program does logic i'm
saying
logic couldn't be devoid of senses
that's essentially what you're saying
yeah but but again a good way to show
that is
programs don't have any senses it just
takes in whatever we give it and it does
logic with it
yeah and again that's what you're saying
yeah but rational science you you don't
need you're saying it's a coincidence
basically
that the assumptions that we make are
based off of the things we've
seen like for example when we see a
pyramid
not how it's built forget that just the
pyramid and we want to explain
how it was built but yeah yeah yeah but
but you're saying it's like it doesn't
matter if we saw it or not you could
have just
you could have assumed it yeah you can
assume
you can make an assumption about a
pyramid for you let's say you never saw
a pyramid in your life you never even
imagined and suddenly you visualize
something you say what if uh there were
a pyramid made of their own
yeah yeah how could it have been made
yeah
you come up with anything i mean you
don't have to see it you don't have to
observe anything
you can just make an assumption you can
make an assumption like i said about god
and about
adam and eve you never saw observed god
and it's a theory
you don't believe in that theory fine uh
other people believe in it
so again it goes through what each
person wants to believe
you might say well that's not science
well neither is space time
what what is scientific about space time
what is scientific about a black hole
what is
scientific about big bang those are all
relationships there's many non-observed
phenomena that we talk about yeah what
is a particle particle is a number
that's what a particle there is no such
thing as a particle in quantum mechanics
not a corpuscle
so what is that did you observe the
particle
it's a collapse of the wave function
that's what a particle is can you do a
review
response to ted kaczynski's manifesto
it's a hot topic on the internet these
days ted kezinski
yeah uh oh about technology you mean
yeah
yeah i don't care about technology too
much uh
ted was uh a little wacko he wanted to
kill some people because he thought they
were making too much progress
um you know i have not much to say about
good old teddy any more than i have
about what was the other guy the guy who
used to
rape women and kill him uh what uh
marilyn manson
no no no there was this fellow he was
putting the electric chair i can't
remember his name now there's a lot of
them that did that
yeah that one guy that one guy who raped
and killed people oh yeah that guy
was a douche [ __ ] that guy that's it for
questions
okay we're done yep okay for free
we'll see you next time anyways uh
continue to beat me up you didn't answer
any questions just sidestep [ __ ] but all
you do is
play freaking hopscotch with questions
you never answered it yeah
it's uh it's called politics play
politics
anyways folks who will see you what is
it on
i'm always at the end of every month
yeah i'm here to beat him up i try to i
try to take people's questions and try
to build them up
yeah he's uh he plays devil's advocate
again i mean
i basically and what i do when he does
adam feed him for a week so he he has
fire
looks so skinny okay we'll see you on
sunday folks bye bye